welcome to the man of Recaps this is The
Walking Dead Daryl Dixon season 1
somehow he's made it all the way to
France so Daryl makes him friends
luckily everyone in France speaks
English there's a kid living here lant
who's a real gentle soul and he and
Daryl hit it off cuz they both have long
hair Daryl's like yeah right good luck
with that I'll see you later crazy nuns
although these nuns are far from
defenseless oh it's an epic killer nun
fight then there's a conductor who's
built himself a zombie Orchestra all
right that's new the club's owner is
this English guy Quinn who also has long
hair in fact he looks EX like Daryl if
he brushed it back but it's like yo you
cheated on me with my sister then tried
to ditch her in the zombie apocalypse
you're kind of a douche they meet up at
the big Paris Landmark the Eiffel Tower
unfortunately even in the zombie
apocalypse it's real crowded with
tourists Daryl's like are you not
entertained and Chucks this zombie head
right at Jana Daryl gives laurant the
battle axe God will forgive you kid
mosio Dixon I will see you later so
Daryl settles in for a bit peeling
potatoes Making Sexy Eyes with Isabelle
and that's where the Walking Dead Daryl
Dixon season 1 comes to an end